[Musique]
le lupin c'est une légumineuse peu connu
en amérique du nord
les italiens les portugais en sont très
friands c'est comme un faible alors au
portugal
on trouva par tourner nous on utilise
comme apéritif en craignent entre avec
une guerre alors souvent se servait
comme un apéritif
pire si la plante est tellement belle et
pleine de fleurs tellement tellement
belle d'aller chez son ami n'en voit
même ici eh oui oui mais aussi au québec
julia et fatima son propriétaire de
l'épicerie portugaise soarès un commerce
qui fête ses 50 ans cette année
moi j'appelle ceux d'élus pas mais vous
vous appelez c'est très moche très moche
[Musique]
comme tout les légumineuses le principal
intérêt du lupin et sa teneur élevée en
protéines le lupin dans les légumineuses
que j'ai regardé je garde entre autres
les pois chiches et les lentilles les
aides hammami le lupin c'est la plus
riche en protéines
donc pour ça c'est vraiment une de ses
particularités de ces richesses le lupin
est un petit peu plus faible en fibres
alimentaires et en faire que les autres
mais ça reste quand même une bonne
source de fer et de fibres alimentaires
puis une demi tasse aux protéines
j'aurais coise que ce serait intéressant
c'est environ 1 15 16 grammes de
protéines donc oui c'est très
intéressant en termes de protéines la
plupart des épiceries offre des lupins
en saumure en pot chez soarès ils sont
également vendus en vrac disponibles sec
leur préparation demande beaucoup de
patience trempage 24 heures cuisson une
heure et surtout une fois qu'il est oui
pour les maîtres alors au minimum 24
heures dans l'eau qui coule tout à les
lui paie ça se mange un peu comme disent
les sens et à la portugaise avait donné
l'impression de manger du fromage en
grain quand on mange parce que c'est
sallie l'eau il faut aussi limiter c'est
vraiment pour la teneur en sel
la teneur en sel varient cela dit
beaucoup d'un produit à l'autre mais
dans une portion d'une demi-tasse 80
grammes environ
ça va jusqu'à environ 2000 mg de sodium
ce c'est presque le maximum qu'on
devrait prendre dans une journée et
sausset dans une demi tasse dans une
petite demie taz
si on veut vraiment la valeur nutritive
du lupin et 500 protéines en fibres
alimentaires
karine de lupin à ce moment là elle
s'est vraiment le la meilleure
alternative pour en profiter parce
qu'elle n'est pas sali s'assemblent en
collaboration avec stéphanie laurent et
frédéric de l'amour du pain ont
développé une recette avec de la farine
de l'upa des jolis petits pains est ce
que c'est une farine qui réagit de la
même façon fine farine de blé c'est pas
du tout le même style de farine parce
que tout d'abord à la pâte butten donc
on peut pas faire un pain directement
qui avec de la farine de lupin ça
s'appellera pas un passe ça va s'appeler
un biscuit ou ça va s'appeler ça va
s'appeler autre chose mais nous on s'est
permis de faire un point où on a
incorporé dans une farine de blé entier
de la farine de lupin la proportion ça
ressemble à quoi
40% à l'est pour aller faire sentir ça
vincent
c'est la ta rennes qui fait c'est ici
ces jours là j'ai vu la souplesse ça
fait vraiment un pain qui est très très
nourrissant puis en plus de ce sommet
leur pain est bon au goût
le matin on peut le tartiner avec un
petit peu de confiture être un bout de
fromage la tuque des gens notre repos ne
déjà mis complète
si on réussit à trouver de la farine du
pain à la maison on peut s'amuser avec
sa ou wii vous à musique
il ya un tas de sortes de biscuits
affaire dont on peut faire aussi à
muffins
mais c'est toujours pareil ça sera
jamais mélanger as à 100% pas falloir de
mélanger à 40% 50% maximum un biscuit on
peut aller jusqu'à 50% parce qu'il ya du
sucre il ya du beurre
on peut élaborer quelque chose curieuse
de voir la couleur de l'ami la farine de
lupin ne se retrouvent actuellement pas
vraiment sur le marché c'est assez
difficile de la trouver il faut la
commander sur internet quand on a envie
attention le lupin fait partie de la
famille des arachides
les personnes qui sont allergiques aux
arachides devrait définitivement parlé
alors allergologue à leur médecin avant
de manger du pain parce qu'il pourrait y
avoir une réaction si je vous lancer un
défi de produire un autre aliment à base
des lupins vous feriez quoi qu'on doit
vous dire tous les secret professionnel
à êtres obligés y avait gardé mon secret
parce que c'est notre prochaine aventure
[Musique]